so right after the Hawaii Emergency
Management Agency sent a fake missile
alert scaring the crap out of everybody
one question remained where the hell was
their governor because even though David
EJ knew the alert was wrong just two
minutes later he didn't tell the public
for 17 long minutes why is that surely
he had a perfect reason for leaving
everyone in a panic was the surf just
too inviting to leave well finally
confess he didn't know his Twitter
password so think about that here's the
state governor who thinks he can only
communicate by Twitter which raises the
question is this state run by teenagers
yeah resign no it's worse it's run by
Democrats which basically are teenagers
with power I mean there are other
options like that to communicate by
there is something called TV and radio
and there's the handy telephone he's the
Hawaiian governor he could have called
magnum p.i ah but he couldn't even calm
a panic without his Twitter password
maybe he should have put it on a post-it
note and left it on the computer like
that other guy did in Hawaii look we've
all forgotten passwords why I keep mine
simple there you go it's gone now but
you don't need a password to stand in
front of a camera and repeat false alarm
go back to bed but apparently Hawaiian
Governance is amateur hour a state run
by Democrats who not only have a hard
time logging on to Twitter but also
reality which reminds me maybe think
twice about ripping Trump over his
tweets at least he knows how it's funny
isn't it you know it's also funny is
that they showed my password for one
second nobody could even read it it said
I love unicorns forever forever so
you're a teenager too hard or ever
teenagers parts what that veep is more
realistic than the west wing yeah it's
so true it's true that this would
actually had about scandal yeah I know I
just I don't watch this you know huge
yet old jumper crazy sure what that's
terrible I watched five I watched five
minutes of scandal and I'm like
so stupid you're lying because you told
me and we used to discuss the episodes
before it was normal
by the way let's get back to bashing
Hawaii that's what we're here for
nope we may need to go there Jessie says
is it weird that he decided that there's
only one way like he could have he could
have said I wait I'm the governor I'll
call Obama
I'll call Obama he could do his Twitter
or you can just call anybody probably
would have done it at least he didn't
email his password to hackers like
Podesta from all these people it's like
Weiner Hilary and the Governor of Hawaii
this is not the best and brightest we
have to offer but I think we should do
what Juan does one apparently has a
Twitter valet intern for the governor
Greg has a wine valet it's amazing how
he pours the wine I should show you a
picture one my mom it seems like this
state is run by like teenagers why are
you backing on Hawaii because after me a
lot of my wife it's going to last a long
time
well I accepted that makes us because
I'm thinking like so why is Greg going
at this thing somebody made a mistake
it's they've come back they say they
said now they're gonna have a two-person
accent so you one person can't make a
mistake in their future why Katie
couldn't pick up the phone these people
win in a few minutes but these officials
knew two minutes but don't you know
people who forget their past yeah but
that's what I mean you go like I don't
know why do I need Twitter Kimberly I
can just talk I am a governor I could
pick up the phone well I mean and don't
you have a communications team and like
someone that knows how to work a device
I mean even if there was some situation
even the president has Dan's Covino yeah
it's not like everybody's working on
Saturday mornings yeah the government
they're probably like no scattered so
what I mean wait guys we know you're on
Twitter predicted or the point that
that's the way you talk it's like
earlier with that you did last week they
had the password was on the post-it note
on the computer I know I mentioned that
it might not a log no because it went so
fast with your Greg loves of unicorn you
know what happened I wish I'd another
headache today my phone started like
like vibrating was going off so much and
it said that somebody was using my
password in another city yep
so I called my wife and I said are you
trying to use my password she said yes
it's like you know snooping on so he
needs to iTunes password music Snoopy